qui est pour qui est contre la science
est levée
la séance est levée
la séance et levée
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Emmanuel Tachet de la
Pagerie député de la 16e circonscription
des Bouches-du-Rhône nous sommes dans le
cadre des derniers préparatifs de la
feria d'Istres dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi visant à interdire la
pratique de la corrida il m'a semblé
importante vous amener à la rencontre
des acteurs de cette réalité économique
sociale culturelle et rural qui est la
nôtre dans cette circonscription
Emmanuel tâché de la Pagerie ces données
une mission défendre la tauromachie
ce député rassemblement national et
l'élu d'une circonscription où le
taureau est roi la Camargue la corrida
se pratique aux arènes d'Arles les
disques c'est ici justement qu'il vient
rencontrer les passionnés quelques
heures avant que les taureaux ne soient
lâchés sur le sable des arènes il est
attendu pour une séance d'initiation
monsieur Galtier
bonjour Alors vous voulez me faire faire
je vous montre ce que vous êtes novice
après ce que vous me dites je vais au
corrida
utilise il y a d'abord la cape et
ensuite la molette donc une cape ça se
tient forcément à demain
alors dis trop serré parce qu'on n'aura
pas d'envergure pour délier l'autoroute
et ni trop large non plus lorsque je la
déploie il faut qu'elle soit présentée
comme un véritable bouclier
voilà
là elle est pas mal voilà
c'est lourd ça pèse un Allemand
voilà parfait voilà le taureau il va
faire ça et là maintenant là-bas
toujours là-bas ok on y va non regardez
la cape elle est pas devant vous voilà
c'est un bouclier lapin très bien voilà
c'est pas mal
de faire est-ce que c'est une légende
qui sont attirées par le rouge ou c'est
juste c'est complètement
blanches ça marche vous la mettez bleu
marron
c'est extrêmement technique c'est
extrêmement esthétique quand on peut
voir le gestes des toreros
et puis bah ça donne envie ça fait envie
de se lancer dans une très hypothétique
carrière de torero le député a un combat
plus urgent à mener le 24 novembre
l'Assemblée nationale doit voter pour ou
contre une proposition de loi visant à
abolir la corrida dans le monde des
arènes c'était échéance c'est très
redouté on espère vraiment que cette
proposition de loi ne va pas être ne va
pas passer pour des raisons économiques
sociales culturelles je vais à la
rencontre de tous mes collègues quel que
soit leur famille et leur groupe
politique pour leur expliquer que nous
avons tous besoin de leur soutien on
arrive désormais à une situation où deux
points de vue là je parle poliment mais
deux blocs s'opposent
un bloc j'allais dire de posture
intellectuelle qui va du rockisme à une
certaine forme de volonté de de détruire
tout ce qui fait notre identité et puis
le monde auquel j'appartiens qui est
avant de concret réel qui ne peut pas
faire de la tradition à fixisme mais qui
veut qu'elle s'inscrive dans l'avenir
c'est ce que moi je défends à
l'Assemblée nationale et sur le terrain
la corrida un sujet éminemment politique
et dans la bataille parlementaire qui
s'annonce les députés sont très
courtisés on nous a pris le temps de
d'appeler chacun des élus que ce soit
dans le sud-est le Sud-Ouest pour voilà
avoir un petit peu leur avis leur faire
comprendre l'importance de la de la
corrida de la tauromachie de la ruralité
de la version au territoire je suis
profondément attaché en tant que député
en tant que plus encore français à ce
que nos exceptions culturelles qui sont
fortement ancrées qui sont traditionnels
vivent et puis s'inscrire dans l'avenir
sans quoi je suis raccord avec le fil
conducteur de ma famille politique
sa famille politique le rassemblement
national
un parti qui a souvent du mal à nouer
des alliances mais quand il s'agit de
défendre la filière taurine le député
trouve des oreilles attentives le voici
avec François Bernardini le maire d'iste
il est président de l'association des
villes taurines de France et soutient
d'Emmanuel Macron j'ai rencontré
Monsieur le Député bien convenu nous
n'avions pas car même des positions
communes
régulièrement
mais nous avons effectivement des
visions sur des aspects qui dépassent je
dirais ces clivages là et moi en termes
de simplement de citoyens qui respectent
la démocratie
je dois effectivement travailler avec
tous les gens qui sont portés à ce type
de responsabilité et je n'ai pas ni de
honte ni d'ennui de le faire à l'heure
où la corrid sa survie l'union sacrée
est donc décrétée chez ses défenseurs
politiques
[Musique]
le spectacle va commencer
Emmanuel Tachet de la Pagerie rejoint
André Vidy
merci à vous surtout cet ancien torero
est une figure incontournable du lobby
torrent
les deux hommes se faufilent au bord de
la piste pour assister à une novillada
c'est une corrida ou de jeunes toreros
affrontent de jeunes taureaux
[Musique]
au fur et à mesure que le combat avance
des bandes sont plantés dans le corps de
l'animal
qui commence à saigner
[Musique]
le sang que perd le taureau là
proportionnellement c'est moins que ce
que vous donnez si vous allez à la
Croix-Rouge pour faire un don c'est pas
beaucoup et les bandes c'est vraiment
minime alors quand on les regarde elles
font 5 cm mais le taureau il fait 400 kg
celui-là c'est impressionnant si on n'a
pas le courage de regarder la mort la
blessure en face mais la notion de
souffrance n'est pas la même pour
l'humain et pour le taureau
vient alors le point culminant d'une
corrida les stockades
la mise à mort se fait d'un coup d'épée
placez le plus souvent entre l'omoplat
droite et la colonne vertébrale
la mort est rarement instantanée mais
elle intervient rapidement si le torero
a bien rempli son office
le combat était juste
le taureau a été malheureux le taux
horaire euro a été aussi tout aussi
malheureux on l'a vu
je crois pas qu'on puisse appeler ça de
la torture en fait ça me choque pas si
c'est la question je crois pas que dans
les abattoirs les images soient aussi
agréable à voir mais je crois qu'il faut
se garder de toute forme de sensiblerie
anthropomorphique un taureau sauvage
n'est pas un être humain
cette vision du député n'est pas
partagée par tous ces confrères pour
d'autres élus au contraire la corrida
est un spectacle insupportable
donc je pense que à l'Assemblée c'est le
député France insoumise Aymeric Caron
qui porte le fer
il est l'auteur de la proposition de loi
qui vise à interdire la corrida dans
l'exposé des motifs il écrit en
affirmant solennellement que la torture
et la mort d'un animal ne peuvent
légalement constituer un divertissement
digne de l'éthique contemporaine nous
ferons un pas historique en faveur des
droits des animaux
dans son combat aymeric Caron n'est pas
seul sur le terrain les militants
anticorrida préparent eux aussi la
guérilla parlementaire nous sommes à
Arles dans la circonscription des
manuels tachés de la Pagerie
la présidente de l'Alliance anticorida
elle aussi est en ordre de bataille pour
convaincre les députés de voter pour la
loi Caron document à l'appui les
militants de son association vont
frapper aux portes des permanences par
le menteur là oui c'est un véritable
lobbying parce que
la
c'est quand même les députés sont quand
même élus et ce sont les représentants
du peuple il va lui dire exactement ce
qu'est la corrida parce que ici chez
nous dans le sud la corrida on sait ce
que c'est mais c'est tout dans les
autres départements passer 100 km au
nord personne sait ce que c'est une
vraie corrida les gens d'ailleurs vous
disent toujours mais il y a encore la
mise à mort en France
la corrida c'est un taureau qui est
supplicié avec à peu près un mètre 50
d'armes blanches qui perfore son corps
donc effectivement le taureau souffre
parce que au même titre que l'humain le
tour ressent la douleur et on ne peut
plus accepter ce genre de cruauté de
barbarie sur un animal juste pour le
plaisir soyons clairs mais au-delà des
derniers instants du taureau les
défenseurs de la corrida insistent
souvent sur sa vie avant les arènes
dans les grands espaces de Camargue
voici un élevage de toros brabos les
torobrave cette espèce s'importait
d'Espagne et celle qui finit sa vie face
au torero donc là c'est un petit lot de
taureau que j'ai on peut voir que le
sucre sur la gauche là c'est un petit
tour qui va faire 3 ans un taureau de
corrida il va à la reine à partir de
l'âge de 4 ans donc c'est qui passe
quand même 4 années
les terres qui l'ont vu naître
de manière complètement extensive il ne
rentre pas à l'étable
je connais pas de bovins qui qui vivent
4 ans minimum dans un cadre aussi
magnifique
c'est un animal magnifique le taureau ça
représente la force à la virilité
et pour moi c'est mon Dieu taureau il y
a une forme de déification autour de
autour de l'animal c'est pas la première
pour le riche des statues pour les
honore qu'on les respecte et la corrida
d'ailleurs participent grandement à ça
autour de l'animal
c'est pas c'est pas rentable pour la
viande parce que c'est au métro de temps
à faire du poids et ça nous coûterait
trop cher et c'est un animal et c'est
une race qui crée qui existe pour finir
dans la reine pour le combat elle peut
pas être utilisée pour autre chose
si la corrida disparaît l'impact
économique sera donc important dans la
circonscription
mais déjà si on a voulu la corrida ben
nos élevages disparaîtront plus aucune
raison que ça existe parce qu'on aura
plus de débouchés du tout
après ça va être une perte je pense
économique pour pour les villes une
ville comarle le maire annoncé qui avait
des routes jusqu'à 12 millions d'euros
de retombées sur deux feria
il y a aussi d'autres petites villes qui
organisent des feras pour les commerces
pour nos restaurants c'est très
catastrophique s'il n'y avait plus la
feria ou la Feria du riz tout à fait
sauver la corrida en France c'est un
choix d'abord éthique mais qui a aussi
des conséquences économiques le 24
novembre le débat n'a pas eu lieu à
l'Assemblée Emeric Caron a retiré son
texte au dernier moment dénonçant un
nombre trop important d'amendements
rendant impossible son examen
sur les 612 amendement déposé 58 était
signé Emmanuel Tachet de la Pagerie
[Musique]